[Musica]
[Applauso]
quando avevo circa dieci anni un mio
cugino appassionato di oriente
mi fece conoscere un gioco di strategia
simile agli scacchi i go go è un gioco
di origine cinese
forse il più antico gioco da tavolo al
mondo ancora oggi giocato con più di
3000 anni di storia
nonostante la semplicità delle sue
regole e anche dei giochi più complessi
al mondo infatti pensiamo al fatto che
possa avere più di dieci alla 170
posizioni legali nella tavola da gioco
per fare un confronto e pensare quanto è
grande e questo numero il numero di
atomi dell'universo è stimato essere
circa 10 all'ottanta la complessità di
questo gioco è tale per cui scienziati e
ricercatori si sono nel tempo sforzati
di trovare una soluzione informatica con
l'intelligenza artificiale per riuscire
a sconfiggere un giocatore umano
se pensiamo che vent'anni fa gli scacchi
un computer è riuscito a battere un
campione del mondo di scacchi
questo è stato per un utopia per molti
anni per il gioco del golf è infatti i
migliori software riuscivano a vincere a
malapena con un principiante con pochi
mesi di esperienza da informatico
anch'io ho provato sviluppare una
soluzione che potesse competere con
l'uomo però con risultati veramente
modesti ho avuto molte più soddisfazioni
in realtà
giocando e partecipando a molti tornei
in italia all'estero e ho avuto anche la
grande onore di poter rappresentare
l'italia in alcune manifestazioni
internazionali come per esempio i giochi
mondiali della mente nel 2016 però è
successo un fatto clamoroso
straordinario che ha gettato scompiglio
nella comunità egoistica un software un
intelligenza artificiale sviluppata da
google di mind era riuscito a battere
uno dei giocatori più forti al mondo
il sudcoreano lee sidol questo
immediatamente crea un senso di
smarrimento di grande sconforto in molti
giocatori
in realtà tutti si chiedevano cosa
sarebbe successo da quel momento in poi
cosa sarebbe cambiato nella storia
millenaria del gol dopo tre anni
possiamo dire che grazie all'uso
dell'intelligenza artificiale e dei
software oggi qualsiasi giocatore può
apprendere in maniera molto semplice
molto più veloce
molti dei segreti del gioco è in realtà
anche i giocatori più forti stanno
utilizzando questi strumenti per poter
studiare nuove strategie e imparare
dunque molto più velocemente a giocare
perché vi ho raccontato questa storia
in realtà questo è un evento
fondamentale nella storia del bo però
anche in realtà al momento in cui
l'intelligenza artificiale per la prima
volta riuscita a dare un segnale forte
il problema così complicato era stato
conquistato era stato risolto grazie
alla potenza dell'intelligenza
artificiale almeno una volta avrete
sentito parlare con con sospetto con
pessimismo dell'impatto che
l'intelligenza artificiale può avere
nella nostra società nelle nostre vite
in realtà credo che sia una fonte di
grande ottimismo per quello che riguarda
la nostra società le nostre vite e vi
racconterò oggi come con la potenzialità
dell'intelligenza artificiale sia
possibile affrontare sfide come per
esempio quella di aiutare i soccorsi
dopo disastri naturali con un unico
obiettivo quello di salvare vite umane
siamo abituati nelle nostre città a
conoscere ogni singolo angolo ogni
singolo quartiere a riconoscere tutti
gli edifici a conoscere punti di
interesse a muoverci le strade e con i
nostri telefoni riusciamo facilmente a
spostarci e a sapere anche quanto tempo
esattamente ci metteremo a raggiungere
la destinazione dove vogliamo andare
tutto questo è possibile perché le
nostre città sono completamente mappate
sappiamo esattamente tutto quello che
c'è sul nostro territorio
in realtà purtroppo non tutte le città
sono mappate di molti paesi soprattutto
in via di sviluppo o in zone remote del
nostro pianeta non si conosce per
esempio dove sono le strade dove sono le
scuole dove sono gli ospedali dove sono
le strutture importanti purtroppo questi
stessi
queste stesse località sono anche quelle
che sono più spesso soggette a disastri
naturali dovuti anche al cambiamento
climatico
in realtà avere una mappatura del
terreno di queste zone è veramente molto
importante quando si verificano questi
eventi disastrosi perché la macchina dei
soccorsi per poter intervenire non
riesce a capire cosa c'è sul territorio
non sa dove andare intervenire per
questo motivo è cruciale riuscire a
mappare
con gran velocità questi territori ma
come si fa a mappare un territorio che
non è già stato mappato si usano le
immagini satellitari da numerosi decenni
sopra le nostre teste sono stati
lanciati e sono in orbita numerosi
satelliti numerose costellazione di
satelliti che hanno l'obiettivo primario
di osservare il nostro pianeta
osservarlo per permetterci di
comprenderlo
negli ultimi anni sono stati anche
lanciati numerosi satelliti che riescono
ad individuare con una grande precisione
con una grande accuratezza molti
dettagli come per esempio gli edifici
macchine e addirittura alle strisce
pedonali
in questa immagine per esempio noi
diciamo umani vediamo abbastanza
facilmente molti molti oggetti molte
caratteristiche riusciamo a vedere degli
edifici riusciamo a vedere un parcheggio
con molte alto il ponte il mare tutta
una serie di altri oggetti che
descrivono il nostro territorio questo è
il lavoro che fa un analista geospaziale
e cioè identificare manualmente tutti
questi oggetti con l'obiettivo di
crearne una mappa digitale visto che
questo lavoro è particolarmente
complicato richiede una grande
precisione e soprattutto nei momenti in
cui ci sono disastri è fondamentale
riuscire avere un risultato quanto prima
di questa mappatura nel 2018 defense
innovation unit una organizzazione parte
del dipartimento di difesa degli stati
uniti ha lanciato una sfida
internazionale con l'obiettivo proprio
quello di usando l'intelligenza
artificiale identificare tutta una serie
di oggetti per riuscire a mappare il
territorio ea rendere molto più veloci
così le operazioni di soccorso dopo un
disastro naturale
lo studio map la start up
ora che ha fondato insieme ad angela
corbari ci siamo da tempo concentrati
nello studio e nell'analisi di immagini
satellitari e abbiamo colto questa sfida
e cercate il nostro contributo
l'obiettivo di questa sfida appunto
identificare 60 classi di oggetti in
immagini satellitari
ma come fa come si allena l'intelligenza
artificiale per riconoscere degli
oggetti essenzialmente come noi
insegnato ai bambini a riconoscere un
oggetto nello stesso modo alleniamo i
modelli l'intelligenza artificiale in
questo caso per esempio vediamo diverse
tipologie di aerei sono sempre aerei ma
hanno colori stili sfondi diversi
piccoli dettagli che differiscono
l'intelligenza artificiale impara a
distinguere quali sono le
caratteristiche distintive di ogni
classe di ogni tipologia di oggetto che
vogliamo them pari ed è in grado di
astrarre e differenziare le diverse
categorie di oggetti
dopo mesi di duro lavoro voglio
presentarvi quella che è la soluzione
che noi abbiamo proposto in questo
concorso e che è stata una delle cinque
migliori soluzioni presentate in questa
sfida
vedete che andiamo a evidenziare diverse
categorie di oggetti con diversi colori
e in questo modo riusciamo a individuare
tutte le macchine tutti i mezzi tutti
gli edifici diverse altre vetture come
anche i vagoni dei treni la ferrovia
tutto questo ha l'obiettivo di mappare
il territorio con l'obiettivo di far
capire
alla macchina dei soccorsi dove e come
intervenire rapidamente nel migliore dei
modi è stata veramente grande la
soddisfazione di essere riusciti a
raggiungere questo risultato essere uno
dei vincitori di questo importantissimo
concorso però in realtà la soddisfazione
più grande è quella di aver
automatizzato questa procedura lenta e
questo ha permesso alla macchina dei
soccorsi di velocizzare e tutti i
soccorritori sono riusciti ad andare
molto prima a salvare vite umane
sono sono molte le sfide che ci
attendono nei prossimi anni nei prossimi
decenni sfide veramente molto importanti
per il nostro pianeta come la storia del
goccia un po insegnato l'intelligenza
artificiale all'inizio ha portato un po
di senso di smarrimento però poi si è
dimostrato essere uno strumento che ha
aiutato i giocatori a trovare nuove
forme ea migliorarsi e allo stesso modo
credo che oggi in questa epoca di
trasformazione d'ingresso
dell'intelligenza artificiale nelle
nostre vite sia veramente un'opportunità
enorme per comprendere meglio noi stessi
comprendere meglio la nostra società è
anche il nostro pianeta grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]